pour le désastre écologique provoquée
par la marée noire avec ces chiffres
affolants plus de 300 mille oiseaux
seraient souillé par le mazout
à l'heure actuelle un dixième d'entre
eux a été recueillie sur le littoral
atlantique où tout est fait pour les
aider à survivre l'entr'aide
internationale avec l'arrivée de
spécialistes américains anglais écossais
dans le morbihan près de vannes
louis carzou et marcel martin ont suivi
l'un des quatorze des terrines air en
mission les images qui vont suivre sont
parfois difficiles sur les plages
abandonnées
c'est une chanson que connaît bien d'art
rock donald car c'était cosset de 34 ans
est un spécialiste des marées noires de
l'arabie séoudite à la nouvelle zélande
mais lorsqu'il s'est retrouvé
aujourd'hui sur la plage de saint
jacques dans le golfe du morbihan
il avait la triste impression d'être un
peu à la main c'est particulièrement
éprouvant pour moi parce que c'est fou
de bassan nom sur cette plage et ce
n'est la récolte que de la dernière
marée eh bien ce sont des oiseaux qui se
reproduisent en écosse chez moi d'une
certaine manière ils rentraient chez eux
et les gnomes sur ce pays d'à rock est
arrivé ce matin au centre de tête près
de bad avec 13 entre vétérinaire
biologiste et spécialiste animalier
venus de grande bretagne des états unis
et d'afrique du sud
leur mission rendre plus efficace le
travail des 130 bénévoles du centre car
maintenir la température nettoyer les
plumages ou assurer la nourriture chaque
soin apporté aux oiseaux mazoutés doit
suivre un protocole précis
attention on line pour éviter la glotte
comme pour effectuer sa première
réhydratation de guillemot
d'accord ok pendant quelques heures mais
on voit quelle heure et a évolué sans
souci ça nous donne encore plus ça nous
motive encore plus net d'experts rendu
tout laisser sert encore par l'ampleur
des dégâts sur la faune car pour se
rendre compte de l'étendue du massacre
da rocha n'est pas allé sur une nouvelle
plage ou à la déchetterie municipale de
bornes ça les oiseaux c'est ce qui lie
allègement évident dans une marée noire
on les voit couverts de mazout mais les
gens doivent être conscients que les
trolls pollue tous absolument tout
l'écosystème il ne faut surtout pas se
dire bof
après tout ce ne sont que des oiseaux
aspo marmonne dans le golfe du morbihan
pour recenser le nombre d'oiseaux morts
c'est désormais la tonne qui sert
d'unité de mesure
si l'on peut encore parler de mesure la
marque